able to speak too as i described him the
man himself the chancellor rishi sunak
joining us at from middlesbrough great
to see you this morning chancellor um
in terms of the budget it strikes that
it was perhaps a kind of a tale of two
halves there was plenty within it about
the road to prosperity one eye on the
future
but also quite a bit on how we pay for
it we'll deal with the second in a sec
in a second but but just in terms of the
announcement on freeports which is
why you are standing where you are what
will these seven free ports be able to
do
that the eight that we shut down in 2012
were not
so what we announced yesterday neil were
eight free ports and eight english
regions across the country
and what freeports are they are special
economic zones
which have different rules that are
going to attract jobs investment and
trade to places
like t-side where i'm now standing and
i'm incredibly excited about what this
means we said we would level up
opportunity across the country
freeports are an example of us doing
that it's a policy that we can now fully
pursue
in a unique british way now that we've
left the european union
and we've had great reaction to it we
had lots of people bidding
to be free ports and in areas like this
where steel was a fantastic industry of
the past and as we look forward
you know my my vision for the future of
a place like this is
teasport can be the place where we do
carbon capture and storage offshore wind
we're already manufacturing vaccines
here
all of that can happen inside of
freeport with special tax planning and
investment
and that's creating jobs across the
country so it's an exciting agenda
it certainly is but did you share any of
the eu's concerns when it comes to free
ports and the way that they can somehow
be used
sometimes be used to circumvent the tax
system i mean i don't know if you've
seen the film 10 it i have i understand
barely a word of it the one thing that
left out though
was the ability of highness of high
wealth individuals to use free ports to
conceal
some of their wealth actually free ports
are used extensively
across the world uh and the eu is
actually one of the few places that
doesn't use them
extensively everywhere else does for
example in america there are over 200 of
them employing
close to half a million people and of
course all free ports and especially
the ones here in britain will be ones
which we
agree with all the oecd rules around tax
and making sure that customs
facilitations all happen in an orderly
manner following all the rules so i
don't think anyone has anything to worry
about on that
uh front but what they will do is
attract businesses to locate with the
tax incentives
invest in in new equipment new plants
here
create jobs in places like t side or
southampton or liverpool
and i think that's exciting um can we
talk then about
the freezing of them personal tax
thresholds and and to your credit you
did not shy away at the dispatch box
yesterday for spelling out
exactly what this will mean to people i
mean you couldn't have done much more
short of wearing a baseball cap with
this will cost you money written on it
and everyone understands that we all
have our part to play in in getting the
nation's economy back on track
but at the same time isn't it pretty
clear that if everyone who is paying tax
will have
to pay more in tax the people who will
feel that most keenly
are those who have leased to start with
so in terms of the budget yesterday neil
i think you alluded this in your intro
i think the first part of the budget was
to make good on the promise that we
would do whatever it takes
to protect people and businesses through
the remaining stages of this crisis
and the budget announced an enormous
amount of extra support for example
extending furlough through to september
lots more cash support for businesses as
we exit the restrictions
that's the right thing to do now and
that's why we did that yesterday
but i also wanted to be honest with
people honest with the country about the
challenges that coronavirus
has caused us particularly in our public
finances
and i don't think it would be right or
straight to ignore those
let them be someone else's problem to
fix which is why we set out a plan to
address that
but importantly don't don't
come into it they they don't come into
effect straight away and they protect
public services and working people
but there's a question of priorities in
all this which was what i was alluding
to in the questions why we're choosing
to balance this off the back of
of everyone rather than for example the
huge number of high net worth
individuals who have done pretty well
out of this pandemic why is
why someone for example i mean what what
one particular one of the
estimates uh and there are plenty in the
papers a police challenge of it it's
wrong
but if you're earning 11 and a half
thousand pounds now by 25
26 inflation could mean you're earning a
salary of 13 and a half thousand pounds
you'll go from paying no income
tax to paying 186 pounds now i
understand to you and me that might mean
the price of a coffee mug
to other people that's the cost their
kids shoes for the year
so actually freezing personal tax
thresholds neil
is a progressive way to raise money i
think crucially what people need to
understand is
no one's current take-home pay that they
have today is affected or lowered by
this policy
what it does do is remove the
incremental benefit that they might have
experienced in the future
as inflation fed through to their wages
but their current cash take-home pay
isn't affected
and also crucially those on higher
incomes
are affected more by this policy it's a
very progressive policies
and that's something that has been noted
by independent think tanks that are
respected like the institute for fiscal
studies
and others who have who have made the
point that those the richest 20
of households for example will end up
contributing i think about 15 times more
than those on the lowest incomes
that's why this is a fair way to help
solve the problems that we need to but
crucially
no one's cash take-home pay is affected
and it doesn't come into force
just now because we want to support the
recovery in the short term as we are
doing
sure there will be those who agree that
it is progressive surely it would have
been made more progressive by the fact
if you had for example protected those
at the bottom end
not stuck a freeze on them i mean we're
talking about a million more people
paying tax which is a significant
increase we're talking about perhaps
a million more people million and 1.3
million perhaps paying
at the 40 rate i mean that includes
teachers
nurses plenty of people like that how
would you describe people
who will be on that 40 uh tax rate would
you describe them as well off
you talked first of all about people on
on lower incomes i think it's important
to remember our personal allowance
at just over 12 and a half thousand
pounds
is by far and away the most generous
personal allowance anywhere in the g20
group of large uh countries
so we start from the position that that
is already the most approach to
the most generous approach to those on
lowest incomes out of basically any
other major country in the world
we've doubled that personal allowance
over the last 10
years saving those on lower incomes over
a thousand pounds
and also the other things that we're
doing to help people on low incomes for
example increasing the national living
wage
from april of this year above inflation
at a difficult time but that's because
we want to support those on lower
incomes
and that will mean a pay rise of around
350 pounds
for someone working full time on the
national living wage starting in april
so we do remain committed to that
and we start in a strong place with the
highest most generous personal
allowances pretty much anywhere else you
can find
it it is a common theme of interviews
with with particularly conservative
chancellors but with chancellors to ask
them to to rule out tax rises now given
that this freeze you
as announced in the budget yesterday is
due to be in place until 2025
2026 i wonder if we can turn it on its
head can you promise
that there will be no income tax cuts
this site of the next election
uh well what what i am going to
is we're just talking about this budget
for now neil and in terms of this budget
you're you're right why i made something
yes we talked about we talked about
what we took yeah but we talked about
the the allowance freeze and then
the other decision we made is to ask
large companies in two years time to
also
play their part in helping us fix the
problem and i made those choices
as i explained yesterday specifically
because i wanted to protect working
people from
increases in their tax rates so we
honored our manifesto commitment not to
increase the rates of tax on national
insurance
income tax or vat that was important me
to do
and we also wanted to crucially protect
public services
and protect small businesses and that's
why i believe the two measures we set
out yesterday
they are the right measures they're fair
and they will support our economic
recovery
sure just in terms of the corporation
tax rise from 19 to 25
over the over the next few years um i
mean does this
you basically turned a kind of a decade
of conservative orthodoxy on corporation
tax on its head we've been told that
you know if you raise corporation to
actually restrict growth if you cut
it you increase growth i mean is this
the end of the party's obsession with
with the laffer curve i mean certainly
there are plenty of businesses this
morning
that are not laughing
well if you look at our corporation tax
rate it's important that it's
internationally competitive neil
so even after this increase we will
still have the lowest corporation tax
rate
of of what's called the g7 countries the
large economies that we
compete with around the world america
canada germany
italy france so we will have a lowest
corporation tax rate even after this
increase compared to all of them
we were also exempting small businesses
we're protecting them
from the increase so 70 of businesses
won't be affected by the increase at all
uh
we want to protect small business and
also we want to support business in the
short term
to invest and help drive our recovery so
what i announced yesterday was something
called the super deduction
it's a tax cut for business investment
the likes of which we've never tried
before in this country
and i'm hopeful that it will spur
businesses to invest
in new free ports like t-side where i am
today as we've discussed
and that will help drive our recovery
create jobs and support businesses to do
exactly that
completely understand that but of all
this sme owners that have been in touch
with me over the past 24 hours and there
have been plenty of them
the one point that all of them make is
this what about those
big companies the tech giants that have
done exceptionally well
out of all of this i mean amazon google
facebook twitter these these big
organizations
where has been the focus on them in all
of this they've done incredibly well
and frankly some of them won't even be
paying five percent tax
on their earnings so sunil remember
corporation tax is a tax on
profits so by definition businesses that
are doing well and making profits pay
pay a good amount of tax uh which is as
it should be
but you're right to highlight online
companies now and the reality is the way
our tax system works it makes it
difficult to tax these large
global tech companies which is why in
last year's budget
i introduced something called the
digital services tax
where we've levied a percentage charge
on their
turnover because we can't tax them in
the way that we would like to
that's already taking force and what we
are doing now
is working with our international
partners around the world
we are in charge of something called the
g7 group this year so i'm leading that
charge with finance ministers around the
world
to reach an international agreement on
how to tax these large
tech companies properly because that
involves all of us to agree a set of
rules
so we can we can approach it in a common
way but in the short term we have got a
digital services tax which is doing
exactly what you
you've suggested and we will replace
that with an international agreement
hopefully this year
as we work with our other partners at
the heart though of this budget pitch
was was this claim and it has been made
a number of times over the course of the
pandemic by you and a number of other
cabinet ministers that you'll do
whatever it takes to help the british
people
uh through this crisis where was the
support for for the excluded yesterday
we understand that yep those who are
recently self-employed
will be pretty pleased that there will
be an opportunity for them to get some
more money of course after 12 months of
not getting anything
but paye freelancers limited company
directors
those denied furlough they're still not
recognized i'm sorry to kind of bang on
about this but i just want to read you a
couple of tweets that we've had
chris davis is the director of a limited
company he says this
i can't even begin to explain the anger
i'm feeling right now i'm so angry i'm
shaking i've lost my wife my kids
my house my business my savings i'm done
stephen gray
was on the show yesterday what do you
suggest to someone excluded because they
earned a tad over 50k before the
pandemic
but is now down to 80 and still excluded
what should they do
to put food on the table that the mantra
that you have done everything you could
to help everyone who is in need of help
is demonstrably untrue chancellor
so so neil i i couldn't hear all the
details of everything you said
but what i would say is we made a major
improvement in access to our
self-employment scheme
yesterday and it was frustrating last
year we we weren't able to bring in
newly self-employed people because we
they hadn't all filed their tax returns
now that the tax return deadline has
passed uh we were able to announce that
all those people will be more than 600
000
new people will be able to benefit from
the fourth and fifth self-employment
grants
uh that will be in place over the coming
months that's good news
and welcome and i appreciate that people
haven't felt that they've been able to
get the help they want in exactly the
way they want in the time they want but
this is only one element of the support
that we've put in place
so for example we've talked already
about universal credit
support with people's rent through
something called local housing allowance
mortgage holidays bounce back loans a
support that we've given to local
authorities that they can use at their
discretion to support their local
businesses so there's lots of different
things that we are doing
and if you take a step back and you look
at the budget but yesterday what it
shows is that over the course of this
crisis
we will have spent over 30 billion
pounds
supporting those who are in
self-employment and i i'm confident that
that will stand as one of the most
generous approaches to supporting
self-employed people
anywhere in the world